hey everybody it's Charlie we got a new
promo for the crossover episode that's
happening in December to break down for
the three-way crossover so I'll explain
what's going on with that much better
look at the new flash suit and a
breakdown of the first six episodes of
the flash danielle Panabaker also posted
a new clip of her talking about the
season 5 episodes so I'll include that
later in the video too so if you're
brand new to the channel there's a new
round of that flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so first big thing you actually
get to see what the neck piece looks
like here
so there's definitely no chin here and
because they're releasing this official
promo for the crossover episode it seems
like this is what the suit is gonna look
like as of episode 9 which is gonna be
the crossover episode this year so it's
not going to be episode 8 like it would
normally be I have already done a video
about that how the flash is gonna have
its hundredth episode for episode 8 and
they wanted to do their own special
thing so all the shows agreed to do the
crossover one week later than they would
normally do the crossover episodes start
December 9th that's Sunday night because
remember now CW has programs on Sunday
night but it's the flash on Sunday night
even though it normally airs on Tuesdays
the reason why they're probably doing
flash on Sunday night to start the
crossover is because Barry has something
to do with introducing the idea of the
Batwoman character and if Oliver hasn't
gotten out of prison by episode 8 of
arrow then maybe Barry has something to
do with breaking him out of prison just
remember that even though it's gonna be
all the characters in every single
episode it'll be flash for the first
night Sunday night then arrow Monday
night then Supergirl is the last night
probably because they want to have some
fun with the idea of Batman Superman
with bat woman Supergirl
so no legends of tomorrow during the
crossover this year I mentioned in the
last couple of crossover videos that I
posted they just didn't have room for
those characters and they're doing
something else so that's their way of
explaining why they're not around but
doesn't this promo make the suit look so
much better than the last promo they
released I feel like they always sit on
their really good art like if they're
gonna release a promo like you really
wanted to look good and even though all
the best flash promos are usually him in
some action pose like him actually using
the Speed Force or running or doing
something the way they have him facing
camera here just really makes it hard to
see what's going on with the rest of the
costume so after
seeing this I just feel so much better
about the situation even though it is
capital B Bazaar that there is no chin
piece so hopefully that comes back
before the end of the season like I said
though the other real big thing is is
that we have titles for the first six
episodes and basic descriptions so I'll
just break those down now
we already knew about episode 1 the
title for that is Nora obviously pretty
self-explanatory all about Nora
revealing why she came to the past I've
already done a video about that and the
mistakes that she made they're pretty
self-explanatory
but even though we as fans have figured
out most of what's going on with her
character this is gonna be the TV shows
version of that for people that don't
watch YouTube videos like this is who
she is this is why she's doing this this
is what's going on episode 2 is called
blocked that's probably setting up the
idea of cicada being able to take away
people's powers killing metas off so
because it's really early to do a big
villain episode it's probably cicada and
then another lesser meta that has
something to do with blocking people's
powers usually episode titles are a
little bit meta and they refer to all
the storylines in an episode so in the
way that they do at every single year
you learn about the villain the first
couple of episodes and they establish a
couple of big concepts to give you an
idea for what's going on with his arc
and how things work so that when he does
something really crazy later in the
season it makes sense number three is
the one that people were freaking out
about because the title is literally the
death of vibe so a lot of people are
wondering what this means because the
actor Carlos Valdez has not left the TV
show so cisco is still a character but
if he dies does it have something to do
with one of the mistakes that Nora makes
or one of the new mistakes that they
make because a lot of people just assume
that this means that he dies during the
season but he could also be dead in the
future I think he is definitely dead in
the future but the producer said that
while we're worried about the mistakes
that Nora made he said that they would
continue to make more mistakes and that
probably has something to do with
erasing people from the future because
of things that they do while they're
trying to take Sakata down during the
season so cisco could just be a casualty
of that in the short term but then i'm
obviously expecting him back before the
end of the season so just don't expect
him to be riding the bench for a long
time just think of this as a sensational
title meant to give you a heart attack
and think that he's going to die but i
don't think that he's leaving the show
so just keep an open mind about that
Episode four is called newsflash
obviously you know news iris West is a
reporter it's really more reference to
the villain spin who has the ability to
make people's fears come true but the TV
show version that they're going with is
gonna put more of a social media spin on
that Episode five is called all dolled
up that's probably a reference to
ragdoll the villain from the comics
that's coming onto the show we don't
know exactly what the characters gonna
look like they're still filming episode
four right now as of me posting this
video so if we get pictures of him on
the street I'll include that in my next
video but I'll wait to talk about him a
little bit more till we learn more about
what's going on with the actual episode
of the way that the TV show plans on
using him episode six is called the
icicle cometh and that's obviously a
reference to Caitlin so it's probably
all about her backstory in introducing
the character that's gonna be playing
her father this season so remember last
season we found out that she got into
that accident she manifested so she
predated the particle accelerator
explosion
so she was either in an accident as a
child her parents did something to her
or her father is a meta and he's going
to be called icicle and she got her
powers genetically through him the way
the casting announcement for that
character reads is that he just shows up
out of nowhere and Caitlin and her
mother have no idea where he's been this
whole time and he's really mysterious
about what's going on like he has
something to hide the deal doesn't
reveal right away so either it's one of
two things like he was a scientist
accidentally gave himself powers through
his experiments gone wrong then passed
them on to Caitlin or he himself was
already a meta and they just passed
those powers onto Caitlin
so I think part of the fun of bringing a
character like her father on is is that
she feels connected to him like oh I
need to love my father I've been missing
in this whole time usually the way drama
twists like that go down though is that
you find that the person that showed up
out of nowhere and pretends to be your
friend winds up having some mysterious
evil agenda so I think the idea is they
want to keep Caitlin's storyline in this
morally great area where she can be both
killer frost and the caitlin character
that's all sunny and happy at the same
time then the logical culmination of her
arc is that she learns to balance both
personas so that she can use her killer
frost powers and she can be Caitlin
whenever she wants to
but speaking of which
Harrison wells that they've been talking
about on the show is supposed to be more
militaristic and have secrets of his own
so he'll be like a shadier version of
Harrison wells that's a little more
hardcore imagine the shooty stabby
version of Harrison wells from earth-2
that we first met during season two in
the shadier version of HR from the early
season three episodes before they
totally learned to trust him see this is
what I'm talking about what even is this
are you doing what are you doing what or
are you really you know you're hiding
something he's been burned twice by a
man with the same face as me I imagine
it's hard to trust after something like
that the only thing we don't really know
is which earth he's gonna be from and
whether or not he will ultimately help
the team out or hurt them
here's that shortened clip of danielle
panabaker talking about some of the
episodes this season I'm super excited
to be directing my first episode of
television and I'm so glad I get to do
it with everybody here on the flash I'm
directing episode 18 which won't film
until much later in the season probably
in February of next year do we get the
origin about killer frost I you know
Caitlyn still on a mission to find
killer frost so I'm excited for you guys
to see how that that turns out let me
know in the comments what do you guys
think about all this
what do you think about the new flash
costume and we're about due for another
trailer so there should be more footage
dropping sometime in the next week or
two I'll name a new giveaway winner when
I post new DC but click here for a brand
new Dragon Ball super and click here for
brand new flash thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight
[Music]